look we've been talking about this over
and over and a lot of you just continue
to not believe it or understand but the
facts are real this headline is no
LinkedIn is winning it's
killing for people and not just
lawyers and financial advisors and B2B
SAS sales people if you're in B2B and
you're not making content on
LinkedIn you're missing out on
opportunities like you're doing cold
calling and going to conferences and
having meetings and yet the content on
this platform can create the business
you're hoping for but I'm talking about
people that are selling fitness
equipment and wine and t-shirts and
Brandon hats and coffee and everything
that you would do on Instagram and Tick
Tock and Facebook the shit's popping
like crazy on LinkedIn and yet people
continue to not listen please go
get yours the getting is happening on
LinkedIn it's real it's it's a real
platform real engagement real virality
potential
take LinkedIn serious it's not
LinkedIn 2013 anymore
the social network